احنا الان طلبت فلسطين في السودان
موجودين بعد من الخرطوم تقريبا ما يعادل
ساعتين او ثلاث ساعات ولكن بسبب الطريق
والمشاكل اللي واجهناها في الطريق طلعنا
منه الصباح من الساعه 2:00 من الساعه 2:00
صباحا على اساس نقدر نوصل على الساعه
ثمانيه هنا من الساعه تنتين لما تحركنا ما
حركنا الا خطاب من السفاره ونزل كشف من
السفاره باسماء الطلاب اللي قالوا انهم
يتحركوا علينا الكشف هذا كان في تقريبا
117 اسم غير العائلات 117 اسم بناء على
كشف السفاره قالوا لهم تعالوا من الولايات
اللي في الولايه البعيده يجي من الولايه
اللي هو فيها بناء على كلامهم جابونا على
اساس انه حتتحرك البساط على الساعه ثمانيه
احنا الان قاعدين في الشارع قاعدين في
منطقه هنا
اراك سيتي بحيث انه مش لاقيين مكان نقعد
فيه فعليا الشباب تجمع الشباب الموجوده
الان هنا ما يعادل تقريبا 120 شخص